Whether it’s two-strokes or four, one cylinder
or eight, most of the engines we use today
are powered by the internal combustion of
fuel and air; however, mixing gasoline and
oxygen isn’t the only way to generate the
energy needed to propel a craft, and in fact,
sometimes it’s the least efficacious choice.
In the typical gasoline-fueled car engine,
power is produced in the cylinders, each of
which is comprised of a shaft with a tightly-fitted
piston that moves down to draw in air and
gasoline.
As the intake valve closes, the piston moves
back up, compressing the mixture and increasing
its temperature (and thereby, efficiency).
When the plug sparks, the gasoline is ignited,
and the released heat and energy in the ensuing
explosion drives the piston back down.
On the other end of the piston (opposite the
intake valve and spark plug) is a connecting
rod that is attached to the crankshaft.
Thus, when the piston is forced down, it pushes
the rod, which moves the rotating crankshaft.
This process works so well that it has been
replicated hundreds of millions of times in
everything from chainsaws to Ford F-150s.
However, this method of producing energy relies
on oxygen present in the atmosphere to combine
with the carbon in the gasoline.
In space, of course, the reason no one can
hear you scream is because there’s no air
(or oxygen).
Enter rockets.
A rocket doesn’t rely on a crankshaft, but
rather on the expulsion of something, be it
gas, liquid, solid or simply radiant energy,
through a small opening (nozzle).
Therefore, unlike a truck that doesn’t need
to carry its oxidizer since it can draw air
from its surrounding environment, ships with
rocket engines have to carry all of their
propellant with them.
Of course, it would be impractical (if not
impossible) to haul enough gaseous oxygen
up into space to have a meaningful flight.
To get around this problem, alternatives have
been developed, primarily in the forms of
solid and liquid propellants.
Solid propellants come in two main types – homogenous
and composite.
With both, the fuel and the oxidizer are stored
together, and power is produced when the two
are ignited.
Homogenous solid propellants are unique in
that both the oxidizer and the fuel exist
together as a single, unstable compound, either
as simply nitrocellulose or together with
nitroglycerine.
On the other hand, with composite solid propellants,
the fuel and the oxidizer are distinct materials
that have been combined into a powdery or
crystallized mixture, which is commonly comprised
of ammonium nitrate or chlorate, or potassium
chlorate (as the oxidizer), and some type
of solid hydrocarbon fuel (similar to asphalt
or plastic).
Solid propellants have long been used with
launch vehicles, including the Space Shuttle’s
launch boosters that each produced 3.3 million
pounds of thrust.
With liquid propellants, there are three main
types: petroleum-based, cryogenic and hypergolic.
All three of these propulsion methods store
their oxidizers and fuels separately until
thrust is needed.
When rockets fueled with a liquid propellant
are fired, a bit of each (fuel and oxidizer)
is introduced into a combustion chamber where
they combine and ultimately explode – producing
the necessary power.
Petroleum-based liquid propellants, as the
name implies, mix together a petroleum product
(like kerosene) with liquid oxygen, which,
being highly-concentrated, renders it an efficient
and powerful propellant.
As such, this method was widely used for many
rockets, including the first stages of Saturn
I, IB and V, as well as Soyuz.
Another liquid propellant relies on cryogenic
(super low temperature) liquefied gases; one
common method mixes liquefied hydrogen (the
fuel) with liquefied oxygen (the oxidizer).
Highly efficient but difficult to store for
long because of the need to keep both so cold
(hydrogen stays a liquid at -423F, and oxygen
at -297F), cryogenic propellants have been
used only in limited applications, although
those include the main engines of the Space
Shuttle and certain stages of the Delta IV
and some of the Saturn rockets.
With both petroleum-based and cryogenic propellants,
some type of ignition is required, either
via pyrotechnic, chemical or electrical means;
however, with the third type of liquid propellant,
hypergolic, no ignition is necessary.
Common hypergolic fuels include different
forms of hydrazine (including unsymmetrical
dimethylhydrazine and monomethylhydrazine),
while nitrogen tetroxide is often used as
the oxidizer.
Liquid even at room temperature, hypergolic
propellants are easy to store, which together
with their spontaneous combustibility make
them highly desirable for a number of applications,
such as in maneuvering systems.
Therefore, even though the materials involved
are highly toxic and corrosive, hyperbolic
fuels have been frequently used, including
in the Space Shuttle’s orbital maneuvering
system and, pertinent to the question at hand,
the Apollo lunar module (LM).
Four subcontractors worked under the lead
contractor, Grumman Corporation, to build
the LM, with Bell Aerosystems Company selected
for the development of its ascent propulsion.
Work began on the project in January 1963,
yet engineers were still tinkering with the
ascent engine as late as September 1968, when
Bell’s initial propellant injector was switched
out for one designed by Rocketdyne, the subcontractor
that also built the descent engine.
Driven by a non-gimbaled, fixed-thrust engine
and powered by Aerozine 50 fuel and nitrogen
tetroxide oxidizer, the hypergolic materials
that provided the thrust necessary to get
the LM off the Moon’s surface were so corrosive
that they burned through the engine each time
they were fired (requiring the engine be rebuilt).
As a result, none of the ascent engines for
any of the LMs were tested or fired prior
to lifting the Apollo astronauts off of
the Moon.